so you found the hair routine of your
dreams and your hair is magnificent but
then it just stops working what is going
on I'm Michelle of lab muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and person with high maintenance hair
today I'm going to help you work out why
your products suddenly stop working and
what you can do about it you might need
to change shampoo first changing your
shampoo can make a difference I did a
video about how complex shampoos are and
one big reason is the way they clean is
complicated the one shampoo will work in
different ways to remove different
things from your hair for example this
shows how shampoo cleans an oil the pink
chapels are the surfactants which are
the cleaning ingredients from the
shampoo they break off little bits of
the oil into mini droplets it's actually
even more complex than this a really
runny oil isn't going to interact the
same way with these surfactants as a
really thick sticky oil so some shampoos
might be worse at cleaning off a
particular type of substance from your
hair than a different shampoo that means
if you use a shampoo for a while an
ingredient May might be building up it
could be a styling ingredient it could
be a conditioning ingredient it could
even be something from the shampoo
itself so you might just need to rotate
through a few different shampoos a
clarifying shampoo can also help but a
lot of the time these are designed to be
used every once in a while that might
not be enough to remove filter but it
could still be worth a try you could
have also changed your other products
hair products are pretty complicated so
how they work with each other can make a
difference it's like a group work
assignment but for hair products it
might feel like one product is working
differently but it's actually a
different product that party too hard
and didn't finish formatting the
presentation that you all had to present
like And subscribe for analogies that
help me work through my trauma let me
explain how this works for hair products
conditioning ingredients show up in most
hair products not just conditioners so
they all end up working in tandem you
might have added say a hair mask to your
routine it might be leaving an
ingredient in your hair that your
shampoo can't remove as easily so now it
feels like your shampoo isn't working as
well anymore all you might have changed
shampoos maybe your old shampoo had some
sort of conditioning ingredient that
combined with everything else you're
using gave the right level of
conditioning but your new shampoo is
less conditioning so it kind of feels
like your old conditioner isn't working
anymore maybe if you go back to your old
shampoo your conditioner might feel like
it's working again you might have
treated your hair this is something I am
very familiar with I think we all know
that chemical treatments like perms dyes
straightening and bleaching are really
damaging but it is a bit more
complicated than that you can't just use
a more concentrated conditioner these
treatments will actually change the
chemical structure of your hair so it
won't interact with ingredients the same
way the main thing we care about here is
oxidative damage and the main place this
happens is called the F layer you might
have seen the structure of hair before
if we zoom into the surface of the
outside layer called the cuticle there
is this thin layer of oily substances
attached this is called 18 methyl
icosinoic acid it's like your hair's
natural hair conditioner that is
permanently bonded to your hair when you
treat your hair with some sort of
oxidizing chemical treatment a lot of
this will break off and you're left with
these groups which are called sulfonates
these are not oily they're on the other
end of the chemistry Spectrum where
water is and like water they don't
really stick to oil and this is a
problem because a lot of hair
conditioning ingredients are oily
they'll stick to the oily F layer on
less damaged hair but they will slide
right off super damaged hair so hair
conditioners that are designed for Less
damaged hair are just not going to work
it doesn't matter how much you use plus
your hair is more damaged so it's
getting less conditioned while also
needing more conditioning this is one
big reason why I think a lot of people
have a sort of Crisis after they
radically change their hair I definitely
did it felt like I just ruined my hair
and there was no going back but it
turned out I just needed a different
hair conditioner with more positively
charged conditioning ingredients these
new sulfonate groups on the hair are
negatively charged most of the time and
opposite charges attract so they these
positive conditioning ingredients will
stick more strongly to the more damaged
parts of your hair which is exactly what
you want these ingredients are also
self-limiting which means that once you
have enough attached to your hair it
will get a slightly positive charge so
these positively charged ingredients
will have a much harder time sticking on
so that means your hair is less likely
to get weighed down if you're using more
conditioner here are some examples of
uncharged and charged conditioning
ingredients now all hair conditioners
will have a mix of both categories but
conditioners for damaged hair will
usually be formulated with high inputs
of the charged ingredients so looking
for products with labels like damaged
colored hair intense repair is a good
starting point but these ingredients
also show up in some other conditioners
as well one of my favorite Supermarket
conditioners is the Tony and Guy
volumizing conditioner it has
amodimethicone near the top I never
would have tried this if I wasn't
looking for charged ingredients my hair
is really coarse so I actually have a
lot of trouble with like poofy hair and
I stay away from volume products but
this works really well so chemical
treatments are the main thing that kind
of blasts away a lot of this F layer but
there are other things that can remove
it too the main ones we encounter every
day are UV from the Sun and poor
chlorine these tend to cause a lot less
damage than a chemical treatment but if
you suddenly notice your hair
conditioner stops working after you
start swimming for six hours a day in
summer then this might be worth looking
into your water might have changed a lot
of people notice that their products
don't work as well after they move to a
different location there are a lot of
possible culprits but one of the most
common is tap water some places have
hard water which contains more metal
ions this is mostly calcium and
magnesium and they can interact with
fatty acids and turn into tiny soap scum
particles which stick to your hair and
make it feel dirty fatty acids aren't
really common in most shampoos and
conditioners anymore but you do see them
a lot in solid shampoo and conditioner
bars you might also see them in natural
soaps that are used as poos these are
some names that might show up in
ingredient lists they can also be listed
in the ingredients as some sort of
natural fat or oil like olive oil beef
Tallow coconut oil along with sodium
hydroxide or potassium hydroxide fatty
alcohols don't have this problem and
plant oils don't have this problem if
there's no hydroxide base the reactive
groups stay tucked away in their
structures you two also have some fatty
acids in your sebum which is your
natural oil and that could potentially
react the same way with hard water the
hard water ions can also stick to your
hair especially if it's damaged it is
those sulfonate groups again they can
sort of hitch a ride on them they can
then interact with products that you
might use outside of the shower like
hair serum so have a look in those as
well on top of that these hard water
ions can make some of the ingredients in
your hair products less effective for
example some of those cleanings
surfactants and shampoos don't work as
well in hard water tap water can also
have some other metal ions like copper
and iron these are really bad because
they can speed up oxidative reactions in
your hair so they can mess up how
chemical treatments like bleach and hair
dye work they can produce a lot of heat
and cause way more damage than usual a
lot of hair damage processes are also
oxidative so these eyes could be
speeding them up and making your hair
more damaged and harder to maintain
copper can also turn your hair green
it's in a lot of swimming pools so it
isn't actually the chlorine's fault so
the best thing to do here is probably
try some products that don't have fatty
acids and consider getting a water
softening shower head another big change
that can happen with location is
humidity water has a huge impact on hair
and humidity especially messes around
with your hair shape when you style your
hair you're pretty much just holding it
in place with hydrogen bonds picture
this you and your dog go to an empty dog
park you have a nice strong bond with
your dog you call for your dog dougie
dougie comes running now let's add in a
whole bunch of really friendly dogs your
dogs distracted you're distracted you're
both having all these extra interactions
with other dogs your bond with your dog
is is temporarily weaker this is
basically what water does to your hair
your hair has a whole bunch of protein
the shape is held in place with hydrogen
bonds this is a bit like glue holding
everything in place water also forms
hydrogen bonds so when you dump in a
whole bunch of water puppies on your
hair your hair proteins will start
forming bonds with those instead the
proteins aren't holding onto each other
as tightly so your hair isn't held in
shape anymore and you get frizzy hair
styling products work by adding extra
bonds to the outside of your hair
strands that adds to the hold that the
hydrogen bonds are giving but if you
have high humidity then there's more
water around a lot of those hydrogen
bonds are gone your styling products are
kind of left during all the work and
they might not be enough anymore some
Sterling ingredients can also hydrogen
bonds so these water puppies will also
mess up how they hold as well so if
you're in a more humid place you might
want to try some styling products with
more humidity resistance hormones and
aging might also be changing your
natural hair hormones can change a lot
of the stuff inside your body and even
though your hair is dead it it can still
have an impact for example around
menopause hair tends to become a lot
thinner and there's less oil production
on your scalp that means your hair might
not be getting as much of that natural
conditioning if thinning is a problem
you might want to look for more
volumizing products if your hair feels
rougher then you might want a heavier
conditioner there are also some
medications like isotretinoin and oral
contraceptives they can also lower oil
production during pregnancy hair tends
to grow a lot faster and becomes thicker
but after giving birth that goes back to
normal and you lose a whole bunch of
hair which is pretty disturbing being
really sick or really stressed can also
cause a whole bunch of hair to
prematurely end their growing cycle they
quickly move out of the anagen or
growing phase into the telogen phase and
then fall out this is called telogen
effluvium and the hair loss usually
happens a few months after the actual
stress and that delay means it's a lot
harder to make the connection so a lot
of people end up blaming their hair
products there's also this annoying
aspect of Aging your hair texture
changes but it doesn't like it all
suddenly tones curly or straight you
just start getting more and more
irregular hair strands it tends to start
in your 30s so now some of my hair is
wavier than it used to be it's a bit
like there are multiple hair ties on my
head now my hair feels and looks rougher
than it used to and yeah the bleach
didn't really help but no regrets they
could have also changed the product
formula I left this tool a bit later
because it's kind of obvious sometimes
companies will just change the formula
without telling anyone so double check
if that ingredient list has changed
sometimes the formula can change without
the ingredient list changing as well a
lot of cosmetic ingredients aren't pure
substances they are mixtures so the
exact properties can change with all the
supply chain issues a lot of companies
have had to adjust their formless they
might be getting an ingredient from a
different supplier and that will have
slightly different impacts on the
formula you could also just be taking
the product for granted maybe you love
the product at the start because it made
a huge difference before you were using
a much less suitable product but now
you've been using it for a while your
expectations have risen you've been
spoiled by the product you aren't
appreciating what it's doing anymore
this is really common we did not evolve
to have perfect memories and we tend to
notice things that are new we like
novelty so maybe put that product aside
try a different product for a while or
skip using it if it isn't an essential
product and then see if you can notice a
difference I hope I gave you some
insights into what's going on with your
hair if you enjoyed this video hit the
like And subscribe let me know what
other topics you want me to cover if you
want more hairstyles check out the
playlist here